Speaker 1: Well, we just have so much news after
the long holiday weekend, and we have to start
with arguably the biggest news in the world.
Tulsi Gabbard has left the Democratic Party
and she's done it with a pretty
conspiracy and lie laden video. Now,
this is actually not very big news. I'm sort of
kind of kidding around. It's tongue in cheek.
Tulsi Gabbard is an individual who used to
be a congresswoman representing the state
of Hawaii. And she ran for president and got,
you know, like one kind of like a11 2% support.
And then she although it was obvious to some of us
that she was clearly a sort of populist rhetoric,
reactionary, contrarian of no real substance,
adding no real value to the conversation.
Not everybody understood that even some of
my fellow leftists kind of fell for it. And
she's been more and more outwardly moving to the
right. Speaking at CPAC, the extreme right wing
convention being selected to fill in as host for
Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson. Listen. This
is the final step in her public transformation.
It's really not that much of a transformation.
So here is the video, 80 seconds, in which Tulsi
announces her principled and defiant abandonment
of the Republican Party. Listen closely, because
there's a lot of a lot of nonsense in here.
Speaker 2: I can no longer remain in today's
Democratic Party. That's under the complete
control of an elitist cabal of warmongers.
Speaker 1: Now, elitist cabal
that is very carefully chosen language to
appeal to the reactionary conservative MAGA.
Big Lie. JFK Junior is currently the vice
president type of people. Elitist cabal is
QAnon language. Do not think that the choice
of that language is an accident. Now, I'm not
saying Tulsi is necessarily a Q and one person.
I'm not saying that, but that's language that is
finely tuned and tested to press the buttons in
the brains of very particular people. It's not
an accident, okay? And by the way, warmongers,
remember, Hillary was going to get us into five
wars. Biden was going to get us into five wars.
None of it has happened. None of it has happened.
But they love this. These are just these are
MAGA right wing conspiracy talking points.
Speaker 2: Who are driven
by cowardly wokeness who.
Speaker 1: Remember that wokeness what
they think of as wokeness is the tiniest
sliver of the left. It's not me. It's
not really my audience. It's not the
Democratic Party. It's yeah, it's same old stuff.
Speaker 2: I us bi racial izing, every issue.
Speaker 1: Okay. The criticism that the left
racialize is everything is a way to disqualify
a priori any discussion of racism or racial
inequality that that you go they racialize
everything. Hard right move. She's gone fully in.
Speaker 2: And stoking anti-white racism.
Speaker 1: And that's the other side. The left is
anti-white and racist against whites. The left is
mostly white guys. That's that's the reality.
Speaker 2: Who actively work to undermine our
God given freedoms that are enshrined
in our Constitution, who are hostile
to people of faith and spirituality.
Speaker 1: And again, it's not hostility to
people of faith or spirituality. It's hostility
to imposing that faith of spirituality on civil
government. It's about openly, as Marjorie Taylor
GREENE and Boebert and all of them have said,
saying we are Christian nationalists
and that should be enshrined in civil
law. That's wrong. That's not constitutional.
Speaker 2: To demonize the police, but protect
criminals at the expense of law abiding Americans.
Speaker 1: And remember the number of people
saying defund the police. It's almost zero and
the movement has no power. Reform. Absolutely.
The 10 to 12 point plan I outlined, of course.
But this is, again, their new talking point. But
remember when they didn't like what happened
on January six, they went after the Capitol
Police when they didn't like what happened with
Donald Trump at Mar a Lago. They go after the
FBI. They're not the pro-police, pro-law
enforcement people they even claim to be.
Speaker 2: Who believe in open
borders, who weaponized the national
security state to go after their political.
Speaker 1: Opponents. That's a trump line.
This is a full MAGA person now.
Speaker 2: And above all,
who are dragging us ever closer to nuclear war.
Speaker 1: Isn't the guy threatening the nuclear
war, Putin the one who's actually doing that now?
Speaker 2: I believe in a government that's of
the people. By the people and for the people. Oh,
unfortunately, today's Democratic Party does not.
Instead, it stands for a government that is of, by
and for the powerful elite. Now I'm calling on my
fellow common sense, independent minded Democrats
to join me in leaving the Democratic Party.
Speaker 1: All right. So then she says, leave the
party with me. So she uses all the bad buzzwords
that will make the right love her even more. She
really hasn't been a Democrat for as long as I
can remember. She's essentially a reactionary who
puts her finger to the wind and says, You know, I
didn't get any real attention from the left other
than the small cult of personality. I managed to
kind of coalesce around me because I don't really
bring anything to the table. So let's go to
the place where you don't need to bring anything
substantive to the table. I can just use buzzwords
and talking points and talk about an elitist
cabal and get attention. That's the conspiracy,
right? That's the MAGA, right? Hillary was right
again, guys. She is once again doing the bidding.
Of the Russians. Again, not a Russian asset, not
a Russian agent. This is the type of democracy
destabilizing language that the Russians and
the Chinese and everybody loves. Now again,
you can say, well, look, but listen, good for
them then. Doesn't mean fine. I'm just saying
the idea that she is fundamentally acting in the
best interest of the United States, as she claims,
is obviously not true. She's becoming a great
tool of these authoritarian, right wing regimes
that love to frame the United States as being
unstable, democratically. And quite frankly,
we are to some degree. But it's thanks to people
like this, not that they're pointing it out,
they're causing that, oh, Trump really want
all this different stuff. So here come the
book deals. Here come the speaking engagements.
If you follow the sort of money trail, it leads
to the same type of people they monetize being
anti-woke. They monetize all the stuff that Tulsi
is talking about here. The saddest thing about
the entire Tulsi episode, and it is very sad, is
the number of fellow leftists who were bamboozled
by Tulsi. I'm glad I never fell for it. Go back
to my clip in January of 2019. Watch the video
I do about her. Watch it. And you will see how
obvious it was to me at the time, what she was up
to. Sadly, many of my colleagues fell for it. But.
You can redeem yourself. Now it's becoming
very clear even to many of them, and I've
gotten so many emails from people in the audience
saying, David, I totally fell for it. You were
right. I fell for it. I think this is the final
loop. We can close the envelope and mail it in